[Musique]
j'ai souvent cette pensée je suis sur
mon lit de mort et ma petite fille qui
n'a pas peur des questions dérangeantes
me demande si j'ai bien vécu
j'aimerais lui répondre oui oui parce
que j'ai aimé et pris soin des relations
avec ce qui m'était cher oui parce que
j'ai cherché à mettre en cohérence sans
quoi je crois mes idéaux
avec ma vie au quotidien oui parce que
cela m'a demandé du courage
athènes reprises de me défaire de ce qui
était attendu de moi et oui parce que
j'ai eu la sagesse à certaines reprises
de questionner ma manière de regarder le
monde et de me demander comment vivre
cette vie
mais ces questions ne sont pas réservées
au moment ultime de nos vies est loin
d'être une pensée triste
cette projection dans un futur que nous
aurons tous à vivre me maintient en
éveil
c'est maintenant que le sens de ma vie
se joue et non à sa fin c'est tous les
jours lorsqu'il m'arrive d'agir
différemment de ce que je l'aurais
souhaité que je veux me questionner sur
comment me transformer pour vivre une
vie plus consciente et nourri de sens le
sens le sens n'est jamais donnée davance
ils se recherchent et c'est pour ça
qu'on parle à ce propos de kate il se
révèle il se dévoile
on le perd on le retrouve
mais si le sens est une quête il est
aussi conquête
la première utilisation du mot au xiiie
siècle conquérir nous indique qu'il
s'agit de se rendre maître de territoire
physiques extérieures par la force des
armes
il s'agit aujourd'hui de se rendre
maître de soi de sa liberté de son
destin par la force d'autres armes
métaphorique celle-ci son courage sa
détermination ou sa confiance
mais à la différence de la quête qui est
une recherche parfois sans fin la
conquête trouve par la force de la
détermination qui la caractérise si le
sang ses conquêtes
ces armes sont celles de la philosophie
la question du sens c'est la question
que pose la philosophie dès ses débuts
défini par socrates comme la recherche
ou l'amour de la sagesse
elle commence par l'étonnement et le
questionnement qui en découlent
elle commence par la capacité que nous
avons tous mais que nous avons parfois
perdu de porter un regard d'enfant sur
ce qui nous entoure
un regard intrigué un regard candide qui
interroge ce qui nous paraît évident nos
enfants sont d'excellents philosophe
vous les avez certainement déjà entendu
poser ce genre de question faut-il obéir
si je ne suis pas d'accord
pourquoi est ce que ma grande soeur à un
plus grand cadeau que moi dit maman papa
pourquoi ce qu'il faut gagner de
l'argent pour vivre ces questions loin
d'être théorique ont une vraie portée
pratique car pour pouvoir y répondre
je vais devoir sortir du prêt-à-penser
je vais devoir développer mes propres
arguments personnel je vais devoir
interroger les concepts en jeu qu'est-ce
que l'obéissance
qu'est ce que signifie être d'accord ou
pas qu'est ce qu'un bon qu'est-ce qu'un
cadeau
qu'est ce que l'argent qu'est ce qu'une
vie réussie le sens c'est-à-dire la
signification que je donne aux mots va
orienter ma manière d'agir va orienter
le sens c'est-à-dire la direction que je
donne à mes actions pour les philosophes
de l'antiquité grecque
la philosophie avait une ambition et
c'était la seule aider à mieux vivre
alors il y avait bien une philosophie
théorique 1 l'étude des grands systèmes
de pensée les grandes idées sur la
nature de l'être humain et sa place dans
le cosmos mais la véritable philosophie
c'était une certaine manière de vivre
et quand j'ai fondé lagence de
philosophie tas et en 2013 avec mon
associé marion genèvre c'est cette
ambition là que nous avons voulu
réactualiser pour que la philosophie
puis c'est une ressources intérieures
pour aider à mieux vivre au travail et
aujourd'hui après avoir animé plus de
500 ateliers philosophiques dans une
trentaine d'organisations auprès de 7000
personnes dirigeants managers
collaborateurs de tous niveaux confondus
je suis convaincu que la philosophie est
une ressource puissante pour cultiver
son leadership son management et son
plaisir au travail
pourquoi parce que la philosophie nous
demande d'interroger le sens de nos
actions
elle va nous demander de dialoguer avec
nous même et avec les autres
elle va nous demander d'argumenter pour
asseoir notre pensée sur des fondements
solides
elle va nous demander de mettre en
cohérence ce que l'on pense ce que l'on
dit et ce que l'on fait est loin d'être
l'apanage de seuls dirigeants elle ce
qui nous anime tous ce leadership et ce
qui nous anime tous quand nous sommes au
plus proche de nous mêmes
les armes de la philosophie pour
conquérir le sens sont nombreuses et
chaque philosophe à sa manière les
affine j'aimerais ont partagé 3 avec
vous ce soir
commençons par socrate socrates le père
de la philosophie
qu'est-ce que socrate nous invite à
faire à chercher la question derrière la
question des questions nous nous en
faisons tous les jours des milliers par
jour
mais la plupart ont une visée
opérationnel pratique elle vise à
obtenir une information
comment me rendre à tedx beauvoisine ce
soir une action peux tu faire ceci ou
peux tu faire cela un avis doivent
investir dans ce projet vous connaissez
socrates
c'était un questionneur impénitent mais
quand il se baladait dans les rues
d'athènes
en questionnant ses concitoyens c'est
pas tout à fait ce genre de questions
qui leur posaient ces questions avait
une visée très clair aider ses
interlocuteurs à prendre conscience de
leurs idées reçues et un combattre les
illusions dans un dialogue de platon
dans lequel socrates est mis en scène un
personnage lysimaque se demande s'il
doit enseigner le maniement des armes à
son fils adolescent et ne sachant que
décidé il demande à socrate de trancher
mais socrates l'interrogent est ce
vraiment là le véritable sujet de
discussion que recherchent les imac en
voulant enseigner le maniement des armes
à son fils n'est ce pas un moyen en vue
d'une fin et socrate de nous interpeller
sur une confusion que nous faisons
souvent entre les moyens et les fins et
c'est ainsi que les imac découvre que
son réel souci c'est de prendre soin de
l'âme de son fils est donc la nouvelle
question devient que dois-je faire
que dois-je savoir pour prendre soin de
l'âme de mon fils pour rendre mon fils
meilleur mais aller chercher la question
derrière la question n'est pas toujours
évident d'abord parce que quand on nous
pose une question
nous sommes souvent tenté d'y répondre
nous vivons dans une véritable culture
et un culte du de la réponse j'allais
dire du questionnement de la réponse
mais si c'est compliqué pour nous c'est
aussi peut-être parce que nous avons
peur peur de déranger peur d'être jugé
peur de perdre et de faire perdre du
temps mais combien de personnes me
disent dans les organisations que je
côtoie le temps et l'énergie qu'elle
perde a essayé de répondre à un problème
qui n'est pas le bon problème et j'aime
citer ces paroles qui sont attribués à
einstein qui disait s'il me restait une
heure à vivre et que ma vie dépendait
d'un problème donné
je passerai 55 minutes à m'assurer qu'il
s'agissait du bon problème
le philosophe henri bergson ne dit rien
de différent un problème bien posée est
quasiment résolu s'il nous est difficile
d'aller chercher la question derrière la
question c'est aussi parce que ce genre
de gymnastique remet en cause nos
certitudes remet en cause nos
convictions profondes
je pense que c'est une véritable culture
du questionnement qu'il s'agit de mettre
en place au sein des organisations
une culture du questionnement où chacun
aux questionner chacun ose poser des
questions qui peuvent potentiellement
être dérangeante mais aussi où chacun
ose être questionnés et donc être remis
en question
c'est le prix à payer il me semble pour
cultiver sa clarté de vue son efficacité
la créativité les enquêtes
l'innovation dont tellement
d'organisation parle en quelques mots
socrates
naudy ozon questionner nos certitudes
400 ans plus tard au début de notre ère
on se retrouve avec epictète epictète
est l'une des trois grandes figures de
la philosophie stoïcienne avec sénèque
et marc aurèle epictète nous dit que si
nous sommes malheureux ce n'est pas
parce qu'il nous arrive des choses
malheureuses c'est parce que nous
confondons ce qui dépend de nous et ceux
qui n'en dépend pas nous confondons la
réalité les événements les paroles et
les actions d'autres personnes qui ne
dépendent pas de nous et qui en réalité
sont neutres avec les opinions que nous
nous en faisons avec notre perception de
cette réalité de ces événements des
actes et des paroles des autres et nous
passons un temps fou à essayer de
répondre à des problèmes qui ne
dépendent pas de nous ce qui dépend
vraiment de nous pour epictète ce sont
nos jugements et nos représentations
ces jugements et représentations color
la réalité positivement ou négativement
si je me fais insulter dans la rue par
un inconnu
je peux soins choisir de me sentir
offusqués
si je prends cette insulte pour moi vous
me dire que les paroles proférées par
sept personnes dépendent d'elle et lui
appartiennent une insulte ne le devient
que si je la prends comme tel une
augmentation de salaire pour prendre un
exemple un peu plus extrêmes ou un
licenciement sont des événements neutre
en tant que tel pour epictète si nous
les vivons positivement ou négativement
c'est parce que nous les qu'oloron
positivement ou négativement
l'or n'a pas de valeur intrinsèque
nous dit epictète il n'y en a que parce
que nous avons décidé de lui en donner
alors que nous reste-t-il à faire
attendre que les choses se passent et
puis travailler notre regard epictète
est un peu plus fin que ça il nous dit
qu'il y à deux endroits où nous avons un
réel pouvoir dans la préparation des
événements est dans la réaction que nous
avons à ces événements le pouvoir de
l'art chez ces deux bandes et son arc de
positionner sa flèche de se centrer son
pouvoir est également dans la réaction
qu'il va avoir par rapport aux résultats
mais une fois la flèche parti il peut se
passer tout un tas de choses là puis le
vent ou d'autres facteurs qui dévie la
trajectoire de la flèche
le résultat ne dépend pas de l'archer
épithètes aime citer l'exemple du
capitaine de navire sa responsabilité de
s'assurer que son bateau est prêt à
prendre la mer qu'il est en bon état qui
l'a les équipes bien formées pour être à
bord du bateau qu'il a suffisamment de
vivres pour faire sa traversée
mais une fois l'orage arrivée il
convient pour épithètes de se laisser
aller avec les flots ce capitaine de
navire pourrait être notre manager ou
notre dirigeant philosophe d'aujourd'hui
son rôle sa responsabilité est de
recruter les bonnes personnes s'assurer
qu'elles sont formés qu'elles ont envie
de travailler ensemble
son rôle est également de les aider à
discerner ce qui dépend d'elle et ce qui
n'en dépend pas ce qui n'est pas un
exercice facile et son rôle est
également de les aider à prendre de la
distance par rapport à leurs émotions
l'homme a cette capacité de prendre de
la hauteur par rapport à ces perceptions
à ses jugements et à ses émotions et
pour epictète le plus grand de voir du
philosophe et d'examiner ses
représentations et de nier adhérer
qu'après examen il me semble que c'est
là l'une des qualités essentielles du
leader d'aujourd'hui j'aimerais terminer
avec la philosophe allemande hanna
arendt philosophe du 20e siècle
ce que je dis est très simple écrit-elle
nous devons penser ce que nous faisons
en 1961 à jérusalem alors qu'elle couvre
le procès d'adolph eichmann qui a
organisé le transport de millions de
juifs sous le régime nazi nazis elle est
frappée par une chose sa banalité son
manque de profondeur
les actes étaient monstrueux dit elle
mais le responsable lui était banale
ordinaire comme chacun d'entre nous ni
monstrueux ni démoniaque ceux qui
l'interpellent c'est le manque de
conviction idéologique solide deichmann
ce n'est même pas sa stupidité c'est son
manque de pensée c'est cela le mal
qu'elles identifient comme banal le
manque de pensée non pas la pensée dans
le sens d'organiser des idées en vue
d'un certain bus ou dans le cadre d'un
certain projet non cette pensée là les
organisations savent très bien la
maîtriser et ashman était certainement
très bon dans cette pensée là non je
fais référence à la pensée telle
qu'hannah arendt la conçoit pour elle
penser c'est l'aptitude du coeur à se
mettre à la place de l'autre c'est la
capacité que nous avons à juger et
évaluer les demandes qui nous sont
faites ces s'imaginer se représenter les
choses absentes et donc les conséquences
de nos actes
mais
pouvoir penser de cette manière là il
nous faut savoir au nom de quoi est ce
qu on agit pourquoi est ce que je fais
ce que je fais il nous faut aussi avoir
la capacité à délibérer en nous mêmes
dialogues intérieurs dont parlait
socrates et enfin il nous faut être en
mesure de dialoguer avec les autres
c'est dans la rencontre avec l'autre que
l'on se rencontre soi même que l'on
s'identifie à soi même que l'on devient
un comme dirait rent c'est ce dialogue
là qu'il me semble manquer dans les
organisations aujourd'hui un dialogue
fait de suspension de jugement un
dialogue fait d' écoute active des
propos de l'autre pour nourrir notre
propre pensée un dialogue fait de
cohérence entre ce que je pense et ce
que je fais hannah arendt nous pose les
questions suivantes dans les décisions
difficiles que nous avons à prendre
quelle personne
avons-nous envie d'être à quoi ne
pouvons nous pas renoncer quand on se
regarde tous les jours dans le miroir
pour continuer à être face à nous mêmes
les philosophes dont je vous ai parlé
ont non seulement philosopher mais ils
ont vécu des vies philosophique
ils ont cherché à mettre en pratique ils
ont cherché à vivre ce qu'il cherchait à
transmettre c'est cela qui m'inspire
aujourd'hui est dirigée manager ou
travailler en philosophe pour moi
signifie s'interroger sur qu'est-ce qui
nous fait agir au nom de quoi est-ce
qu'on agit et de pouvoir l'incarner dans
ses gestes quotidiens dans les
transformations d'organisation que je
côtoie tous les jours c'est la chose
qu'il me semble la plus difficile à
réaliser cette exemplarité cette
cohérence entre ce que je pense que je
dis ce que je fais
mais je crois en l'humain qu'il ya en
chacun d'entre nous je crois que chacun
d'entre nous à un moment donné de sa vie
quel que soit son éducation son histoire
familiale son contexte socioculturel se
questionne sur le sens de sa vie et sur
le sens de son travail
pour certains c'est à la fin pour
d'autres c'est à l'occasion d'un coup
dur personal une maladie la sienne ou
celle d'un proche ou d'un coup dur
professionnels n'attendons pas ces
moments graves pour vivre une vie
philosophique
merci
[Applaudissements]